This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. How often do you feel somewhat disconnected from your environment or from your thoughts, your emotions? How often do you find yourself waking up in the morning and immediately feeling tense and alert? How often do you feel the need to be constantly
productive and active only to be exhausted by the end of the day but unable to sleep or unable to accept the fact that you need downtime or maybe you find that no matter what no matter how much caffeine you consume how much sleep you have had you just cannot absorb new information or learn new things the thing about all these statements and what they all have in common is that they are indicative of a stress response called survival mode and if you feel like that you feel like like you spend more time being hyper alert and stressed than relaxed and curious and inspired by life, this stress state may be describing exactly what you're going through. Survival mode occurs when we basically have no energy left to actually be anything more than, I would say, a machine or a
survival machine. We just have to shut down and push through the day. We are operating normally on adrenaline and stress and cortisol and anxiety, basically just trying to survive our current circumstances. Whether that is work related, family related, school related, money related, trauma related, it often ends up turning us into someone when not because all the things that make us have to be shut down by our brain basically in order to preserve energy and to survive whatever it is we're going through. The thing is is that our body and our mind, think that they are doing the right thing, but often our nervous system has become so dysregulated and extremely sensitive from repeatedly feeling overwhelmed or threatened that we are in this state
far more than we perhaps need to be. We all have this very primal ancient system in place for helping us through really dangerous moments. But in the modern world, these systems are often triggered by things that won't kill you, that won't harm you, but would still feel really, really stressful. And being in survival mode for too long can create chronic stress. It can create extreme burnout, emotional, physical, social exhaustion. And it can also just make us feel like we're a bad person, like we've become a mean person or a lazy person. When none of these things are true. We're just trying to survive without maybe all the information, all the support, all the resources that could help our nervous system find its way back to safe mode. So today,
let's talk about it. Why do so many of us in our 20s find ourselves in survival mode far too often when a lot of the world would like to think that we don't have too much to be stressed about? I think we all know that's not true. But why do we feel like we've been this way longer than we can remember and what is actually going on in our body and our brain to make us feel this dissociated and alienated. Above all else, how do we find our way back to a place of not just safety or peace, but of regulation, a place of growth where there is room to be human and room to be vulnerable and actually enjoy life?
I'm definitely no stranger to survival mode myself. I feel like I end up in that space far more than I would. like to. And I'm getting better at admitting that's because I'm not great at managing stress. And there are probably things from the past that I don't manage as well as I should be. And I've learned a lot through that process. I definitely have. And I have so much to share with you today. So much to help you hopefully understand this state. And maybe also understand yourself a little bit better in the process. So without further ado, let's get into it. Let's talk about the psychology, the biology of survival mode.
You have probably heard the phrase survival mode if you're interested in the self-help or wellness space at all if you've been in therapy before, definitely. I really like that this concept and this experience has become more accessible to people, that we actually have the language to describe what we're going through, because not only is it a lot more common, but it's really, really scary. And I think having full information is probably the first step to getting back to safe mode. So as always, let's start with the basics. Survival mode is essentially a psychological and physical state of heightened arousal and awareness. And it occurs when our brain basically believes we
are in danger. And so it activates what is known as our fight, flight or freeze system to basically get us through the situation or the threat. This can be in response to a lot of things. Firstly, really stressful life periods, you know, after a loss, after enduring something traumatic during burnout, that's a really huge one for our 20s when we've kind of been pushing ourselves to our limits and enduring really extreme mental conditions for far too long. Sometimes that can trigger survival mode. And it can also come up in response to past trauma or environmental stresses, like during natural disasters or during war. A big, one that we all went through together was, of course, the pandemic. So many people found themselves
completely exhausted despite being home all the time. Because of how unpredictable and scary the circumstances were, it meant that our brains were constantly in a state of alertness that eventually took its toll on all of our mental, emotional, physical resources. In other words, a lot of us were pushed into survival mode. The important thing to know about survival mode is that, although it may feel totally alienating. It actually means that your brain is trying to do the right thing or what it believes is best, given your environment, given the stress is your experience, given how it's hardwired. And the way that it does that is by essentially switching on the parts of us that are very ancient and primal, which have evolved for millions of years as a way to protect us when it
perceives danger. And the other thing that happens is that it switches off all those distance, that it sees as unnecessary or frivolous. That is the really crucial word to remember here, survival. We want to survive. That is our natural drive. And all of the systems in our body that are controlled by our brain are blindly trying to do that when they encounter stress. The problem occurs when this response is activated for far too, you know, far much longer than it should be. or continues to be activated even when the immediate danger has disappeared.
Like when you're getting flashbacks or relieving something traumatic, even though you are not currently in danger, there is still this sense of urgency and intensity that doesn't subside. There is also the fact that these primal instinctual systems have evolved and adapted for a completely different environment than what we are in now. So there was this fantastic article written back in 2012 by Dr. John Montgomery, and he wrote it for the magazine Psychology Today, which we refer to a lot in the podcast. And basically what he suggests is that we have the brains that we have evolved to have over millions of years. And for the majority, and I mean the sizable majority of human existence, those brains were made for hunting.
and gathering. And they were made for encountering threats and either escaping them, running away from them, fighting back, and that kind of being the end of it. And these threats were very tangible. So many of the threats we encounter nowadays are not. And the best example of that is a sense of threat from social media or online. Like you read a really terrible news article and you're not in any immediate danger. but our brain doesn't know that.
Our brain can't always tell the difference because it just listens to our stress response. And so because it has spent millions, thousands of years evolving to respond in a certain way, it automatically activates that system and it makes us hypervigilant and afraid and anxious, even though the threat is something pretty intangible and probably very far away. So that is where the concept of media overload to take a little, have a tangent here. What I'm specifically referring to is this idea of news anxiety, right? The world feels very dark and dangerous at the moment. And because we are, you know, exposed to all the terrible things going on, even though they don't immediately threaten us, it can actually trigger
a survival mode state. So the American Psychological Association actually spoke about this all the way back in 2012. There is a psychological strain that comes from not only living through, but absorbing all that terrible news. It's where terms like doom scrolling have come from because, you know, social media has definitely heightened that for this generation and with that, it is heightened out automatic states of anxiety and sense of overwhelm and subsequent, some would say like a detachment from reality in order to cope. So this can eventually create a state of hyper arousal where we experience difficulty sleeping or switching off. We're in a constant state of, you know, baseline panic or anxiety.
We could also be really irritable. And we, you know, have these strange emotional outbursts where nothing seems to be wrong. We have these heightened emotional reactions and sensitivity. We get frightened really easily. And we can also be looking for ways to numb ourselves to that and really escape all this extreme nervous and misplaced energy in our body. Survival mode. Whatever has triggered it.
And I said this before, it can turn us into completely different people. You may forget to fulfill your most basic needs, like eating or sleeping or showering, because all of your energy is going towards just getting through what you're going through. It's why people who are in like the real depths of grief often lose a lot of weight, not only because their body is demanding more from them, but you also just don't feel hungry because all of those hunger cues and, digestion is suppressed, right? Like that's part of the frivolous unnecessary systems that our brain is switching off. We may also feel more tired than usual, sleeping 10, 12 hours a day and still feeling
exhausted because those hours that we are awake are so intense and exhausting, we just could never sleep off that exhaustion. It can really get us into such a spiral, especially if you're, you know, survival mode is the result of being an overachiever or from perfectionist burnout. You want to keep pushing, right? That's how you have been, you've almost trained your brain to perform is to keep pushing, but your body is telling you to rest and to restore itself. And so you end up just experiencing even more guilt that means that you end up compensating by extending yourself even further. And that is how we see burnout cycles that turn into survival mode. Our emotional regulation, I think I already mentioned, this also goes out the window.
We snap at our loved ones for the smallest things. We never know when we're feeling sad or mad or bad about a situation. I was actually, in preparation for this episode, I was speaking to my friends. Like when I'm about to do an episode, I love to just kind of like talk to them. We say I bring it up, they ask like, how's work doing? And I said to one of my friends, I was like doing an episode on survival mode. And I was explaining to her like what it feels like, what it means. And she said to me, she was like, after I was in a car accident, she broke her leg in a car accident back in like 2021 maybe, after she was in that accident, even after her leg was healed, she still felt so like emotionally fuzzy.
And she would be angered by the smallest things. And she was like, maybe it was because all of my mental energy was being devoted to processing that trauma and trying not to feel afraid anymore. That's a big part of it. things like multitasking become more challenging. We can't actually relax because it always feels like something terrible is going to go wrong. We have memory issues. You know, it's almost like a zombie state, like a heightened alert zombie state where our brain is kind of switched on, but everything else is really intense.
You know, the other way that I can describe it is there is like this filter between you and the rest of the world, like a blurriness to all your way. hours, all your waking moments, like when you get into a car and like, you know, when you turn on the radio and it can't find a channel, it's just this like high frequency noise and meaningless chatter, that is what survival mode feels like. This specific experience, that buzzing, that high frequency, that noise, that detachment blurriness, that is also indicative of something else going on here. Disassociation. There is a huge correlation between survival mode, and disassociation because detaching ourselves from our emotions and our surroundings is kind of one of
the only ways that our body is able to firstly mentally compartmentalize what's going on but also tolerate hard and stressful things that's why dissociation is known as a stress response often in response to anxiety and it basically occurs when we unconsciously disconnect from our reality as a way of surviving. It's very much an adaptive instinct and adaptive process. You know, disassociation can help somebody feel like they can shut off from overwhelming circumstances by muting, distorting, going on autopilot and pushing through the extreme situation. However, when the trauma is ongoing, even if, you know, the physical trauma has passed, if the memories of the trauma are ongoing. Disassociation can become what some researchers would call fixed and automatic.
Your body is basically saying, listen, we can't trust you with this right now. Trust us. We're going to take over. We're going to numb you all these experiences. And, you know, when it's time to come to, we'll wake you up. Don't worry. We'll get you there. I feel like that so rarely happens because whilst you're in this survival state, you're going to continue to do things feeling like you need to survive. That doesn't include things that are important for self-care. It doesn't include moments of relaxation. It's kind of like you are locked in.
There's no way out once you let this mode take over. So what's actually happening in your body and your brain to create this? Well, we spoke kind of briefly about it before, but it's basically the fight or flight response. Now we also tend to include freeze or fawn. but this is an automatic physiological response to danger. If you have ever done like a basic psychology course, you know about this, but when our sympathetic nervous system takes over in response to a stressor, a stressful event, we get a racing heartbeat.
We get our dilated pupils, a release of adrenaline and cortisol, our breathing rate goes up. This response is meant to prepare our body to get away or survive danger. The other thing that is meant to happen is that response, is meant to go away when the danger has passed. But if not, if we don't ever perceive the danger as passing, eventually staying in that stress state for too long leads to exhaustion and breakdown. The other thing to note about what's happening in your body and your brain when you're in this mode
is that your brain is operating entirely differently than what it would normally be. The amygdala, which is the part of the brain responsible for emotional processing, especially for things like fear, it becomes hyperactive and hyper reactive. It sends signals to hormones like cortisol, which that's what really triggers your fight or flight response. But when the cortisol tap isn't turned off, you start to get muscle tension and pain and sleep problems. And it even sometimes means that we get sicker more often.
So this is interesting. If you've like just done a series of exams, if you've just graduated, whatever, you've just done midterms and you've been pushing and pushing and pushing and pushing, do you ever notice that you immediately get sick straight afterwards? That's basically what's happening here. Obviously, that's just like a brief period of stress. But when we live in survival mode for months on end, it's basically like having a stress are constantly poking you,
constantly poking and poking and poking and you can never relax. And over time, this disrupts the body's natural balance. and it puts you at risk for a whole lot of mental health issues, also physical illnesses like we spoke about before. There was a series of studies published in Scientific America back during the pandemic that showed that prolonged stress can even alter our brain's structure. It can lead to long-term memory issues, reduced academic performance, poorer decision-making, and if you think that wasn't enough, our prefrontal cortex, which controls, Rational Thinking also seems to kind of take a back seat. It seems to be almost overwhelmed by, you know, the parts of the amygdala or the inner
cortexes that are really just shooting out danger signals at all time. This is also why we see a difference between what we would call a learning brain and a survival brain. If you've ever noticed that the more stressed you get, the more difficult everyday tasks become, that is because you are experiencing this difference. the difference between learning brain and survival brain. A learning brain is one that is really able to take in new information. It also means that you're able to perform daily tasks that you're accustomed to without much issue.
You don't find those tasks stressful or frustrating. And there is all this space for creativity and for inspiration and for growth. Your brain is clear and it's just soaking everything up. If you're experiencing, currently experiencing, I will say a healthy life. You have managed to really navigate your stress response. You've taken care of your mental health. You're on holiday. You're probably in learning brain mode.
It's why when you go on vacation, right, you suddenly have like a million ideas for your future. And you're suddenly so much more relaxed. And you're really interested in going to museums. And you have all these plans and all these ideas and you're reading. Your own learning brain. Survival brain is what we described before. There is no space for anything new.
there is no space for new information, for curiosity, everything is done on adrenaline and on fear. If you're just trying to survive, your brain is focusing only on what it thinks is important for your survival. So if you are, you know, you've just experienced something traumatic and you step into a classroom or you step into work and you have all these tasks to do, you're not going to be able to do them. And there's this brilliant YouTube video from a creator called Jacob Hamm. and he talks about this so perfectly. He talks about how individuals who have endured a lot of trauma as children or people who have just escaped toxic situations, toxic workplaces who are burnt out, they are operating on an empty tank.
It takes so long for that tank to be replenished. And so, yeah, it may look like you're lazy or you're procrastinating and you're disorganized, but actually when we have a bit more compassion and we look deeper, it's because your brain is still in that survival mode. it doesn't see learning as a current priority. To sum up all this doom and gloom, this can have a bleed-on effect. It's really hard to be a good partner or a good girlfriend or a good boyfriend when every part of your brain is looking for danger.
There is no room for softness when you're just trying to survive. And it can mean that you often self-sabotage your relationship or, you know, if you're really, really irritable, it's not that you have an excuse for being angry or agitated. but it's really hard to think clearly about what you want from your relationship and how to show up as a good partner if there's no brain space for that. The same goes for friendship. You know, I've seen really great, amazing friendships fall apart because one person just had no mental capacity to be present.
It was for no other reason other than that they were stuck in the survival mode. And everything to them became less important because they were just trying to get through. And when all your cues and your drive for sleep and hunger and water and socializing, when all those cues are out of whack, when your immune system is compromised, it's really hard to pull yourself out of that and to kind of find your way back to who you were before. Who were you without the stress, without the tension, without the adrenaline, without the fear? That is exactly what we are going to talk about next, exiting survival mode, getting back to safe mode, back to our learning brain. I have all of the tips and the psychological advice I could
find that I could extract from the research. Stay with us after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with Wright. researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here. unpack what went down and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
I don't think there's a more important year for black. people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person
while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at
Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Being in survival mode is not a conscious choice. I really want you to know that. and to know that if you've identified yourself in these descriptions that I gave, this is not something that you are actively putting yourself through it. It's not your fault. You're not an angry person, a bad person, a mean person. Maybe you're just trying to get to the other side and that's something I can hopefully help you with.
Getting from survival mode into safe mode means finding a way to tell your brain and cut through the noise and communicate with it that I'm safe. It's okay. There is no threat. I'm not in danger. thank you for trying to protect me, but you can take a backseat now. I can take control. That starts by creating an internal and external environment where you don't feel threatened or alert, where there is no reason for your brain to be on all the time.
And I think that that really begins in your physical space and in your surroundings. Sometimes we can't escape the environment that is keeping us in survival mode. But if you can, your mental health is going to thank you. Whether that means leaving a toxic home, a toxic roommate situation, a toxic work environment, those are the places we need to create change first because it is so often outside stimuli and our environment and the places that we exist in that are creating these high levels of stress. If you're, you know, restricted by finances or obligations or leases, make the space that you can within that. create a routine and a room, a home that prioritizes comfort that gives you a place to feel secure and peaceful. Basically, find your oasis. For most people that is going to mean their bedroom or their room,
我认为这真的始于你的物理空间和周围环境。有时我们无法逃离那个让我们陷入生存模式的环境。但如果你能逃离，你的心理健康会感谢你的。无论是离开一个有毒的家、一个有毒的室友环境、还是一个有毒的工作环境，这些都是我们需要首先做出改变的地方，因为往往是外部刺激、我们的环境以及我们生存的地方产生了这些高水平的压力。如果你受到财务、义务或租约的限制，就在这些限制内尽可能地打造你的空间。创建一个优先考虑舒适的日常起居和房间、一个家，它能给你一个感到安全和平和的地方。基本上，找到你的绿洲。对大多数人来说，这意味着他们的卧室或他们的房间，
I think the first thing that you can do to bring a sense of comfort and calm is warm lights. I know that's like the silliest tip to include, but there has been a lot of research in the last 10 years showing how light can affect our mood and our stress response. Just think about how alert you are in that intense blue clinical lighting that tends to make us feel very awake and very alarmed and overstimulated versus soft lighting that imitates our natural environment. That has been shown to reduce cortisol levels and to realign us with our natural circadian rhythm and melatonin release schedule, all things that are big pluses for getting out of survival mode. Less noise, less stimulation is also fantastic. because that means fewer things your brain feels alert to and might perceive as danger. Even better if you can find a space like your room that is phone free and you can escape the
我认为你能做的带来舒适和冷静感的第一件事就是温暖的灯光。我知道这听起来是一个最傻的建议，但在过去的10年里，有很多研究表明光线如何影响我们的情绪和压力反应。想想看，在那种强烈的蓝色临床照明下，你是多么警觉，这种光往往让我们感到非常清醒、非常惊慌和过度刺激，而模仿我们自然环境的柔和照明则不同。这已被证明可以降低皮质醇水平，并让我们重新调整到我们的自然昼夜节律和褪黑激素释放时间表，所有这些对于摆脱生存模式都是巨大的加分项。更少的噪音、更少的刺激也很棒，因为这意味着你的大脑觉得需要保持警惕并可能将其视为危险的事情变少了。如果你能找到一个像你的房间这样没有手机的空间，你就可以逃离
doom scroll, you can escape the work emails, you can escape the negative news cycle, the constant to-do list that is infiltrating your downtime. That can make such a small difference. There's a reason why a lot of people suggest having times and having a big period during your day where your phone is not present. I think all of these practices can actually help us become very aware of the triggers or the stresses which are immediately in the moment pushing you into a fight or flight state.
无休止的刷手机，你可以逃离工作邮件，你可以逃离负面新闻循环，逃离不断渗透到你休息时间的待办事项清单，那就更好了。这能带来微小的改变。许多人建议在一天中留出时间和一大段时间不看手机是有原因的。我认为所有这些实践实际上都可以帮助我们高度意识到那些立刻将你推入战斗或逃跑状态的触发因素或压力源。
That simple act of noticing, you know, do I feel better when my phone is off? Do I feel better when I'm leaving a certain environment versus another? Do I feel better when I'm not seeing this person, when I'm taking something off of my to-do list? that is something to really notice because when we remove sources of stress, even just tiny ones, that can make a real difference when you're in survival mode. This is kind of the same premise behind why we might value a routine during this time.
这种简单的察觉行为，你知道的，我关掉手机时感觉更好吗？当我离开某个环境而不是另一个环境时，我感觉更好吗？当我不见这个人时，当我从待办事项清单中去掉某些东西时，我感觉更好吗？这确实是需要注意的事情，因为当我们消除压力源时，哪怕只是很小的压力源，当你处于生存模式时，也能带来真正的改变。这有点类似于为什么我们在这个时期会重视日常规律的前提。
Routine often means less unpredictability, less to be uncertain about, less to adapt to out of the blue. And it can help us ease into a calmer, less. alert state where we know what's going on, we know what's happening, we feel in control, there is less pressure and instinct to be on all the time. Part of that is also thinking about what you can take off your plate. You know, I've mentioned burnout. Burnout is a huge contributor to survival mode in our 20s. It's such a simple philosophy, but if there is less to do, less to stress about, there is more mental space for honestly healing and just silence. There is more mental space to give back to you.
规律通常意味着较少的不确定性，较少需要去猜测的事情，较少需要突如其来的适应。它可以帮助我们放松到一个更平静、不那么警觉的状态，在那里我们知道发生了什么，我们知道正在发生什么，我们感到一切尽在掌握，时刻保持紧绷的压力和本能减少了。其中的一部分也是思考你可以从盘子里拿掉什么。你知道的，我提到过职业倦怠。职业倦怠是我们二十几岁时陷入生存模式的一个巨大推手。这是一个非常简单的哲学，但如果要做的事情更少，需要焦虑的事情更少，就会有更多的精神空间来真正地疗愈和享受平静。会有更多的精神空间留给你自己。
Here's something that I want to talk about and that I want you to remember. Sometimes our busyness is actually hyper arousal in disguise. And it's the instinct to be doing something always, to constantly be on and constantly be productive and moving forward and fixing problems as a way to self-soothe and as a way to give that anxiety somewhere to go because it feels like you are fixing your stressed state by getting rid of triggers or getting things off the to-do list or getting the project out of the way or making, you know, like maybe I could go to sleep, but if I clean my house, I'll just feel a little bit better tomorrow morning. It's like, no, the reason sometimes we want to be more busy is because
这里有些我想谈谈并且希望你记住的事情。有时我们的忙碌实际上是过度觉醒的伪装。这是一种本能，总是要做点什么，不断地处于开启状态，不断地高效、向前推进、解决问题，以此来自我安抚，并给焦虑寻找一个去处，因为这让人感觉你通过摆脱触发因素、清除待办事项、搞定项目或者，你知道的，也许我可以去睡觉，但如果我把房子打扫干净，明天早上我会感觉好一点，你就是在解决你的压力状态。这就好比，不，有时我们想要更忙碌，原因在于
we are trying our hardest to find a way to reduce our sense of arousal and alertness by getting more stuff done. That's something that really like blew my mind when somebody said it to me. They were like, you think that maybe you're busy because your thoughts will spiral if you're not, or because you don't know what to do with that empty space, or because everything that isn't done feels like a stressor to you. But when you force yourself, and I mean force yourself to just stop, pause, do it tomorrow, give yourself the afternoon off, there becomes all this space where you can just really sit with your big emotion,
我们正竭尽全力通过完成更多的事情来寻找减少觉醒感和警觉性的方法。当别人对我说这句话时，这真的让我大开眼界。他们说，你可能认为自己很忙是因为如果不忙你的思绪就会陷入疯狂，或者因为你不知道该如何处理那些空闲空间，或者因为所有未完成的事情对你来说都像是压力源。但当你强迫自己，我是指强迫自己停下来、暂停、明天再说、给自己放个下午假，就会腾出所有这些空间，让你能够真正地去面对你深重的情绪，
and just be like, okay, I'm not doing anything right now. I'm not trying to fix anything. I'm not trying to do anything. And I'm not dying. And I'm not in danger. And the world has not collapsed. It's basically a learning experience for yourself. It's basically being like, okay, when I do force myself to face whatever it is I'm going
然后告诉自己，好吧，我现在什么也没做。我没有试图解决任何问题。我也没有试图去做任何事。我也没有死。我没有处于危险之中。世界也没有崩溃。这基本上是一次给自己的学习经历。这基本上就像是在说，好吧，当我强迫自己去面对我正在经历的任何事情时，
through, when I do force myself to just be present and alone and to feel all the instincts that I'm feeling, I'm not going to die. this is just this constant need to be productive. It's just a survival or a defense mechanism and I need to consciously reprogram that. I think it's also really important to put time aside to do things for you that are just naturally going to make you feel more relaxed and to once again fight the urge to be prepared for the next disaster by doing things. We can't talk about safe mode without talking about self-care and I'm not talking about the kind of
当我强迫自己去保持当下、独处并感受我所有的本能时，我是不会死的。这种对高效的持续需求只是一种生存或防御机制，我需要有意识地重新编程。我认为留出时间做那些自然会让你感到更放松的事情，并再次通过做事来对抗为下一场灾难做准备的冲动，这也是非常重要的。我们在谈论安全模式时不能不谈自我关怀，而我指的不是你在社交媒体上可能看到的那些光鲜亮丽的自我关怀，你知道的，面膜、水疗日。如果这在你的经济能力范围内，你绝对应该去尝试。但在那之前，我们需要优先考虑一些真正丰富且在心理上滋养的自我关怀练习。我们需要找到一种自我服务和自我调节的方法。很多事情超出了我们的控制，这一点大概是显而易见的。但在我们控制范围之内的是我们如何回应那些把我们推入这种兴奋状态的事物。
glamorous self-care you might see on social media, you know, face masks, spa days. If that's within your means, you should definitely go for it. But we definitely need to prioritize some seriously rich and psychologically nourishing self-care practices before we do that. We need to find a way to self-serve and self-regulate. A lot of things are beyond our control that much is, you know, probably obvious. But what is within our control is how we respond. to the things that push us into this aroused state.
自我安抚和神经系统调节是我们工具箱中的一部分工具。其前提是，如果我们能够刻意地平息压力反应，我们就能阻止自己自动进入生存模式，并阻止我们被战斗或逃跑反应所支配。帮助我们做到这一点的自我关怀练习应该包括充满能量，同时也要提供空间来缓解某种紧张或压力源，或者找到一种方式，我总是想象这就好像一个火球向你砸来，而你找到了一个
And self-soothing and nervous system regulation are part of kind of the tools that we have in our chest. The premise being, if we can calm down our stress response deliberately, we stop ourselves from automatically entering survival mode and we stop ourselves from being ruled by basically our fight or flight response. The self-care practices that help us with that should involve filling up your cup, but also providing the space to relieve some kind of tension or stressor or to find a way to kind of, I always imagine it's like a fireball is being thrown at you and you find a way to
扭转它并把它扔回去的方法。你知道的，你找到了一种方法，让你能够处理压力以及任何向你砸来的东西，并基本上摆脱它。一些大的方面显然像是自然散步、运动，我最喜欢的节目之一就是大自然治愈的力量以及大自然如何帮助我们调节、自然调节我们的神经系统，我绝对会推荐运动，而且你真正喜欢的运动是另一个选择，运动是一种天然的压力释放方式，我不会长篇大论地谈论运动及其对我们心理健康的影响，它显然比那更复杂，但你知道，你必须记住
twist it and throw it back. You know, you find a way that allows you to process the stress and process whatever it is that's being thrown at you and essentially get rid of it. some big ones are obviously things like nature walks exercise one of my favorite episodes of all time is the healing power of nature and how nature helps us regulate naturally regulate our nervous system i would definitely recommend movement and movement that you actually enjoy is another one movement is a natural stress relief i'm not going to go on about a tangent on exercise and its impact for our mental health it is obviously more complex than that but you know you've got to remember that
当你奔跑、运动、击打沙袋、骑自行车、去普拉提时，这需要消耗能量。有时这确实有助于我们消耗掉一部分肾上腺素和皮质醇。尤其是全身运动，比如渐进性肌肉放松和有节奏的运动。这非常有价值。如果你去过那种，它们叫什么来着？就像是一种有节奏的运动课。就像是一种有节奏的运动课，比如舞蹈课，但你基本上是根据你身体压力所在的位置做出反应，并据此运动和释放它。太棒了。太棒了。它是如此整体，对吧？我想有时整体医学、整体疗法和整体疗愈如果这种说法名声不佳，直到你亲身体验过，
when you run, when you exercise, when you box, when you cycle, when you go to Pilates, there is energy required in that. And sometimes it helps us really burn off some of that adrenaline and burn off some of that cortisol. Full body movements, especially, like progressive muscle relaxation and rhythmic movement. That is so valuable. If you've ever been to like a, what are they called? It's like a rhythmic movement class. It's like a rhythmic movement class, like a dance class, but you basically, like, respond to where your stress is in your body and you move according to that and release it. Amazing. Amazing. It's so holistic, right? And I think sometimes holistic medicine and holistic therapy and holistic healing if that sort gets a bad rap until you do it,
然后你会觉得，哦，不，不，我完全懂这个。我完全明白为什么这么多人这样做。另一个我非常喜欢并永远支持的大事，我在自己的生活中看到了它的好处，而且最近变得越来越受欢迎，是一种叫做情绪释放技术的东西。它可能更广为人知的名字是敲击法。这可能是你听过的名字。这是一种相对较新的做法，但它基本上是一种将敲击我们身体的某些部位与重构我们的思想相结合的方法。比如在思考一些非常 stressful 的事情或对你的待办事项感到恐慌时，慢慢敲击你的前额。或者，你知道的，另一个例子是，当你正在重温你在以前有毒的工作场所经历的一次非常糟糕的遭遇时，慢慢敲击你的眼睛正下方。所以如果你现在想尝试一下，想想一件让你感到超级焦虑、超级困扰的事情，
and you're like, oh, no, no, I totally get this. I totally get why so many people do this. Another big thing that I love for myself and I will always endorse, I have seen the benefits of this in my own life and it's becoming so much more popular recently is a thing called emotional freedom technique. It's probably better known as tapping. That's probably what you've heard it as. This is a relatively new practice, but it's basically a method of combining tapping certain parts of our body whilst restructuring our thoughts. So slowly tapping your forehead whilst thinking about something really stressful or feeling panicked about your to-do list. Or, you know, another example is slowly tapping right underneath your eye whilst you're reliving a really awful encounter at your old toxic workplace. So if you want to try it right now, think about something you're feeling super anxious about, super troubled by,
然后缓慢而温和地敲击你的眉毛上方，然后是你的眼睛下方和嘴巴上方。专注于那个压力点，看看你的身体是否有反应以及是如何反应的。我一做这个，总是能获得极大的平和与平静。这项技术首先是基于一些非常了不起的科学，同时也基于传统中医原理。你可能会认为这是安慰剂效应。换句话说，这全在我们脑海里。
and slowly and gently tap just above your eyebrow. and then just below your eye and above your mouth. Just focus on that pressure point and just see if and how your body responds. The moment I do this, I'm always brought so much peace and calm. And this technique is based on some really amazing science firstly, but also traditional Chinese medicine principles. And you might think it's placebo. In other words, it's all in our head.
我懂的。我一开始绝对是怀疑论者，因为我认为我们非常习惯于被开具的正常疗法。但如果它没有临床支持的话，我想我是不会提出来的。而情绪释放技术绝对有。基本上，它感觉如此之好以及它确实能降低我们的压力反应的原因在于穴位刺激。而穴位刺激可以促进杏仁核中血清素的释放，我们之前说过，杏仁核基本上是大脑的恐惧中心，同样在前额叶皮层，它字面意义上会向血液中释放鸦片样物质、血清素、GABA（这是一种平静的神经递质）。所以你立刻被
I get it. I was definitely skeptical because I think that we're very used to the normal kinds of therapy that we are prescribed. But I don't think I would mention it if I, if you know, it didn't have clinical backing. And EFT definitely does. Basically, the reason that it feels so good and the reason that it does reduce our stress response is because of acupoint stimulation. And that acupoint stimulation can promote the release of serotonin in the amygdala, which we spoke about before, basically the fear center. of the brain and also in the prefrontal cortex, it releases quite literally like opioids, serotonin, GABA, which is a calming neurotransmitter into the bloodstream. So you're immediately flooded
大脑中的快乐化学物质以及身体和大宗大脑中的平静化学物质所淹没。它有助于调节皮质醇水平，即压力荷尔蒙。正如我们所知，皮质醇往往会随着心理压力而上升。所以当我们对此进行抵制时，它在某种程度上为我们可能达到的高度设置了一个上限。你可以在网上找到情绪释放技术的疗程，最近的临床研究表明，这种特殊的技术作为一种长期的治疗工具，在处理过去的创伤方面有很大的前景，特别是我们所知的童年不良经历。它还可以帮助我们从——我经常谈论这个——有毒的工作环境、有毒的人际关系、有毒的住房状况中恢复过来，还有许许多多
with both happy chemicals in your brain and then calming chemicals in your body and in your brain as well. And it helps regulate cortisol levels, the stress hormone. And that tends to rise, as we know, with psychological stress. So when we counteract that, it kind of puts a ceiling on how high we can go. You can find EFT sessions online and there's been recent clinical studies that have shown that this particular kind of technique has a lot of promise as a long-term therapeutic tool for working through past trauma, specifically what we know as adverse childhood experiences. It can also also kind of help us recover from, I've spoken about this one a lot, but toxic work environments, toxic relationships, toxic housing situations, so many.
不同的情况。原因在于情绪释放技术基本上帮助我们纠正了创伤反应。因此，当类似于创伤体验的事情发生并且我们的战斗或逃跑系统启动时，我们可以通过强加放松来重新连接我们的反应，从而刻意地、自动地、自愿地让自己脱敏。而不是觉得我们的外部环境或这个触发因素突然控制了一切。这有助于调节我们的神经系统，使其处于更多的副交感神经状态（这与交感神经状态相反），而不是那种时刻处于高度警觉的过度觉醒状态。
different situations. And the reason why is because EFT basically helps us correct trauma responses. So when something that resembles a traumatic experience occurs and our vital flight system kicks in, we can basically deliberately, automatically and voluntarily desensitize ourselves by imposing relaxation to rewire our response. Rather than feeling like our external environment or this trigger suddenly has all the control. This helps regulate our nervous system to be in a more parasympathetic, which is the opposite of sympathetic state instead of that hyper aroused state where you are always on alert. Finally, try and bring forth your learning brain when you can. Once you have hopefully created that small slice of peace and safety for yourself and your little home oasis of
最后，尽可能展现你的学习大脑。一旦你希望已经为自己和你的小家创造了那一小片和平与安全，并在那里你感到舒适、你知道自己是安全的、你知道自己是受保护的、你知道一切尽在掌握，试着引入能让你受到启发或感到兴奋的事物，看看是什么能让你进入心流状态，无论是画画、跑步、电子游戏还是乐高，字面意义上任何能让你在几分钟内忘记周围世界的事情。请想办法多做那些事情。任何能帮你彻底放松的事物。现在，我要给你一些快问快答式的建议。
comfort where you know you are safe, you know you are secure, you know you are in control, try and introduce things to be inspired or excited by, and see what brings you into a state of flow, whether it's painting or running or video games or Lego, quite literally anything that just for a few minutes makes you forget about the world around you. Please find a way to do more of that. Anything that helps you switch off. Now, I'm going to give you some rapid fire tips. I've gotten from therapists along the way for getting out of survival mode back into safe mode.
这些是我从治疗师那里一路学来的，关于如何摆脱生存模式并回到安全模式的建议。这听起来可能显而易见。如果可以的话，就别再喝咖啡因了。减少咖啡因和酒精的摄入。不言自明，我正是出于这个原因不再摄取咖啡因了。这需要一段时间来适应，而当你最终习惯了不再觉得你的能量水平依赖于某种实际上能非常迅速且非常容易让你陷入压力状态的东西时，那种感觉真是太棒了。我现在注意到，即使我喝了一杯抹茶或健怡可口可乐（虽然我很少喝），我也会变得非常神经质。我立刻会感到
This one might sound really obvious. Just stop drinking caffeine if you can. Drink less caffeine and drink less alcohol. Self-explanatory, I no longer drink caffeine for this very reason. It takes a while of getting used to and it's just like amazing when you eventually get accustomed to not feeling like your energy levels are relying on something that's actually very, they could very quickly and very easily put you in a stressed state. And I notice now, like even if I have a matre or like a diet Coke, which I rarely do, I get so jittery. I immediately feel like the burden and the
我经历过的和必须要做的一切事情的负担和压力。因此，咖啡因和酒精是我们尤其想要避免的物质。有时是因为我们经常使用这些物质来自我安抚或补偿我们失调的神经系统。我们可能会觉得它们起到了作用。它们要么让我们平静下来，要么在我们精疲力竭时增加我们的警觉感，但从长远来看，它们实际上会使情况变得更糟。这只是又一个我们不得不依赖的人工交互或人工情况，它打断了我们身体自我调节的自然能力。
pressure of everything that I have ever experienced and have to do. So caffeine and alcohol in particular are substances that we want to avoid. Sometimes because we often use these substances to self-soothe or compensate for our dysregulated nervous system. We might feel like they're doing something. They're either calming us down or increasing our sense of alertness when we're exhausted, but they can actually make it worse in the long term. It's just one more artificial interaction or artificial situation that we have to become reliant on that interrupts our body's natural ability to regulate itself.
还要追求快乐的活动。我之前差不多已经提到了这一点，找乐子。快乐让我们快乐。它也让我们平静。它带来了平和的状态，因为如果你的大脑正在体验快乐，它基本上会自动假设，你知道的，我们一定是安全的。一定没有什么不对劲的地方。所以这是回到安全模式、激活副交感神经系统的好方法。
Also pursue joyful activities. I kind of already mentioned this, but doble. Perman makes us happy. It also makes us calm. And it brings about a state of peace because if your brain is experiencing pleasure, it basically automatically assumes that, you know, we must be safe. There mustn't be anything wrong. So that's a great way to get back into your safe mode, activate your parasympathetic nervous system. And practice self-compassion, practice radical self-compassion, loving yourself for no reason, accepting what you're going through. Instead of trying to, immediately feel better and get better and get back to the person you were before, the person
练习自我同情，练习彻底的自我同情，无缘无故地爱自己，接受你正在经历的一切。不要试图立刻感觉好点、好起来，回到以前的那个自己，那个不急躁、什么都能做到的自己，只需花点时间。因为这是一种强烈的状态。达到这一步需要付出很多。所以无论你经历过什么，你仍然值得来自你自己的爱和同情。在别人给你之前，你首先值得从自己这里得到它。只需认识到你不是超人。尽管你无法一下子做完所有事情，尽管你可能一直在经历各种事情，你的福祉仍然值得优先考虑。现在，至少你对自己的处境有了更多了解。你可以看到事情往往就像多米诺骨牌效应一样。
who wasn't irritable, the person who could do everything, just take some time. Like this is an intense state to be in. It takes a lot to get here. So no matter what you've been through, you still deserve love and compassion from yourself. Before anybody else can give it to you, you deserve it from yourself first. And just recognize that you're not superhuman. Your well-being is still worth prioritizing despite you not being able to do it all at once, despite what you may have been going through. Now, at least you have some more information about your circumstances. And you can see how so often it's almost like a domino effect.
我们只是没有意识到事情变得那么糟糕。我们只是没有意识到我们陷得有多深，我们离生存模式有多远，直到我们环顾四周，意识到也许我们感到如此脱节，我们已经脱节了几个月，甚至几年。而你甚至能够认识到这一点这一事实表明，也许你比你最初想象的更接近逃离那种状态。所以我希望你有所收获。我希望你从中带走了一些东西。我希望这里面有些东西你可以在自己的生活中实施。一如既往，如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时通过那个心理学播客与我联系。如果你想让我们进一步深入探讨，
We just don't realize that things are getting that bad. We just don't realize how deep in we are, how far into survival mode we are, until we kind of look around and realize that maybe we feel like so disconnected, we felt disconnected for months, for maybe years. And the fact that you are even able to recognize that shows you that perhaps you're closer to escaping that state than you might initially think. So I hope you learned something. I hope you took something away from this. I hope there is something within here that you can implement in your own life. And as always, if you did enjoy the episode, feel free to reach out to me at that psychology podcast. If you want us to expand on it further,
如果你有另一个话题建议，请确保在苹果播客或声田上关注我们。我只想说。我们很快就会推出一些非常酷的节目。所以希望你在附近收听。请务必给我们五星好评，特别是如果你觉得这很有用的话，以便其他人也能接触到并找到这些内容。一如既往，直到下一次，保持安全，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点，我们很快就会再聊。2%。
if you have another topic suggestion, make sure you're following along on Apple Podcasts or Spotify. I'm just going to say it. We've got some pretty cool episodes coming out soon. So hopefully you're around to listen to them. Make sure you give us five starts as well, especially if this is something that you found useful so that other people can reach this content and find this content. As always, until next time, stay safe, stay kind and be gentle to yourself, and we'll talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
这是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了坚韧意志、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你将会作为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即 IHeartRadio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的 T.W.O.%节目。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会时，她们决定自己动手。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T.W.O.% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcast. or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
他休想逃脱惩罚。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。相信我，宝贝。在 Iheart radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。我懂你。在《回看过去》播客中。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I got you. On The Look Back at it podcast.
从1979年开始，那对对我来说是个大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员，
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians,
以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回看过去》。
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
嘿，最近怎么样，伙计们？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《艰难学习》。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着铠甲？
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor?
它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着因为你有这种能力，你就需要这样做。在 AHA 广播应用或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证是真人。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。
It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这向世界发出信号，表明你是不容小觑的。而且，仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在iHeart广播应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Hard Way》。这是一档iHeart播客。保证真人录制。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。